You might have seen this already,
but I want you to watch us.
It's a political ad,
Charles Close
the city of San Francisco this morning
citing the escalating
crime and fentanyl crisis.
That even happened in San Francisco.
Even like get shut down.
Oh, okay.
I was like this.
Hey, a recent
ad from the Republican National Committee
imagines a dystopian future
if President Biden is reelected.
Emboldened China invades Taiwan,
but all isn't as it seems.
So all the images in that ad
were actually created using
artificial Oh, my good. Wow.
Images are powerful,
you know, and that this ability to create
so many images so rapidly,
it's an incredibly powerful tool.
New artificial intelligence
technology makes it easy
to create fake images
that can look very realistic,
like these created by artist and online
trust and safety expert Tim Boucher.
This kind of image
making can be democratized
at such a scale
and that basically anybody can use it to
to impact the global conversation on
on pretty much any topic.
And the comfort of his garage
turned workshop in Canada,
he has created all sorts of fake images
imagining Vladimir Putin as a hippie.
Governor Ron DeSantis at Disney,
even President Reagan
surrendering to the Soviets.
He says he's creating the images
to make people more aware
of the powers of A.I..
Some people will just say,
you are creating misinformation.
Stop doing that.
We don't have that luxury
of waiting anymore.
These things are happening in real time,
and we've got to find ways to
talk about it
and to be up front about what are both
the good things and the bad things
that can come of it.
When political campaigns
have long used advertising
to imagine the disaster that awaits
if their rivals get elected, they're
like this.
1964 ad from President Lyndon B Johnson
that imagined a nuclear apocalypse
out of kilter.
Last year
a fake video purporting
to show the Ukraine president
surrendering to Russia emerged online.
It was a deepfake video made using A.I..
It's not just
I can create a fake audio of you
Joe Biden whomever.
It's that
I can broadcast
with that world instantaneously.
Through social media.
Honey, Fareed is a digital forensic
expert and professor at UC Berkeley.
50% of the use
happened in the first few minutes.
So even by the time I figure out
something is fake.
Hours, days have gone by.
It doesn't matter. It's over.
Millions of people have already seen it.
Greetings to all.
But not all users of this technology
need to be nefarious in India.
I was used to make it look like
this politician
delivered an address
in multiple languages.
This video is a deepfake.
Now Delhi has a chance to change it.
God.
Imran Ahmed, who runs an organization
tracking misinformation
and online
hate, says
the Republican Party's aid
isn't in itself dangerous.
It's a gateway
potentially to much more dangerous uses
of A.I.,
for example,
trying to deepfake
President Biden, saying, I'm well,
welcoming immigrants into the country
or President Biden
saying I'm going to force
everyone to take a vaccine.
Texas already has a law on its books
against certain
uses of deepfakes in the weeks
leading up to an election.
But it's not clear
how enforceable that law actually is.
And you might spot
there's a tiny warning
and a disclaimer
at the top that says it's
made a name for an eye
for national online
While some people
we showed the AI
to outside the White House
knew it was fake.
All of the images in it
are actually fake.
Yes, I would think a video game.
Right. Others weren't so confident.
I don't think I would have known
that was made today.
I if you hadn't said anything.
It's so true.
Every time I see you,
I say it's so scary.
But what's interesting, too, is
I know you've learned
how AI is actually helping campaigns
in terms of reaching voters.
Is that safe?
Well, it's it's scary.
You know,
so we spoke this week
also to a data CEO who runs a company
that targets voters.
Look on every voter.
A lot of campaigns have hundreds
sometimes
thousands of data points about us,
where we live, our demographics,
how we voted for it, said things
like that, who we've donated to before.
He was explaining how A.I.
model systems can be used now
to go through all of that data
and see patterns
that humans wouldn't be able to.
So you're going
to have more access, are more
effective, I guess, targeting of voters.
And also at the same, as you
said, that
some of those emails
will get those annoying
campaigning emails.
Some of them may also be written
by chatbots, written by A.I.
Now, that would not surprise me at all.
Don't you appreciate it as always.
Thank you.